arriving to a sea of press but worlds
away from the red carpet reception kevin
spacey is used to rather than fans
clamoring for autographs photographers
fighting to get a shot of the double
oscar winner walking into court this a
rare public appearance since his career
and conduct has come under scrutiny over
the last five years
the hearing brief confirmation that the
charges relate to alleged sexual
assaults which took place in 2005 and
2013 the 2008 charge had claimed he
caused a man to engage in penetrative
sexual activity without consent
spacey wasn't asked to enter a plea but
in response to the cps arguing that he
shouldn't be allowed to fly home his
lawyers argued that he wasn't a flight
risk that he'd voluntarily submitted to
four days worth of questioning by met
police in new york that he strenuously
denied the charges but understands that
he needs to respond to them in order to
move on with his life
all of the alleged incidents occurred
within the time frame when spacey was
based in the uk as artistic director of
the old vic theatre
i know what you want we've seen little
of him aside from a cryptic house of
cards-esque video posted onto social
media since the metropolitan police
announced its investigation the decision
by the cps to charge the hollywood
a-lister follows a review of that
evidence
a hugely connected figure in the arts in
both america and the uk
spacey's lawyer said he denies any and
all criminality and in a statement last
month the actor said he was confident he
could prove his innocence
granted unconditional bail his next
hearing is at southern crown court in
july casey spencer sky news